yeah yeah sounds good sounds good sounds
good hey hey hey hey hey hey is the
first time we're speaking right now we
haven't talked before this moment today
Oh should it's happened it's a special
trap remix invitations doesn't travel
remix of us so so bay they just asked me
I just Jerry just started a vine hi i'm
gerry and honored and jerry just started
a vine and this is doing guest this is
jank ass dubs it you're just sort of on
and i just posted a vine you know just a
glimpse inside of dank studios you know
what it and bay says but where is the
blue mill in reference to a previous
vine on a different account which is
just like that needs to become a new
thing along with the elephant inflates
you and frost by bowl ross white balls
and you know Franca's toes flank ass
rubs steak spices marinades seasonings
for your next cookout luau or barbecue
they've got a whole hawaiian line as
well yeah Thanksgiving is coming up yeah
caribbean attitude day caribbean jerk I
like I just want to imagine that that
you know the jerk style of seasoning and
marinade isn't named for like a specific
you know thing is just like this real
[ __ ] made this very specific chick
and they're like hey you know that
caribbean jerk yeah that guy's chickens
real good we should be at what's in this
this is like some guy from an island
cousin like an island place that I feel
isn't like why is it called jerk you
know what know why we're recording this
on a computer that it can do a Google
yeah let's do this I have caribbean jerk
I don't even have to type chicken
caribbean's your I spoke Caribbean wrong
or caribbean if it like it's also known
as Jamaican Jerk as style cooking native
to Jamaica and which meat is dry rubbed
or wet marinated with a very hot spice
mixture called jamaican jerk spice jerk
seasoning is traditionally applied to
pork a chicken the term
who said to come from the word charkie a
spanish term of Quechua origin for
jerked or dried meat which eventually
became jerky in English it all right all
right jerk is also derived from the
action of jerking which refer to poking
the meat with holes so that flavor could
be more easily absorbed jerk seasoning
principally relies upon two items all
spice called pimento and Jamaica and
scotch bonnet peppers other ingredients
may include cloves cinnamon scallions
nutmeg thyme garlic brown sugar ginger
and salt so some of those I mean like
theoretically you go hog wild on some of
those it could be similar to barbecue
okay just look like a spicy ask or you
know that explains everything ma you are
you are livin loud right what is it boy
what is it boy somebody in a well is it
just something I in stuck down the old
well did somebody just want to get
through head scratched probably yeah
what if that was like half of all um uh
uh you know what was that dog's name
that dog was a dog lassie oh yeah like
half of all our Old Yeller uh specials
like this really what the dog was trying
to say is just like hey I'm hungry okay
how the all the disasters were just
coincidence yeah it's just like what boy
someone's trapped underneath a beam like
the cold construction site somebody fell
into a being on fire yeah in the barn I
think there was a Perry bible fellowship
um Harry Bible fellow yeah it's a this
very funny calm everybody why don't ya
Perry bible fellowship there was a comic
work guys trapped under a beam in a
burning barn he's telling the dog glass
he go get help border collie runs into
the farmhouse and barks and just get
served food in an eats while the barn
continues to burn hey did that dog was
selfish wasn't paying attention at all I
just like the weird idea that dogs have
some kind of Hippocratic oath but about
like doing heroics saving deeds haha
it's like it's my oath as a dog to
notify people of
aster of human peril Emmett bro I wonder
if that's something that can be read
into a dog that's you know cuz like
aggression can be bred into a dog or
heroin or like chihuahuas are basically
tiny alarms hey man you hear about those
dogs who like you know pick up phones
and call 911 and stuff I've never heard
of that happening how is that possible I
don't know maybe I feel like they must
be bizarrely specially trained maybe
it's not that maybe just dogs who have
done [ __ ] that are helpful in crisis
maybe 911 is like a speed dial button
and they can be trained to press
specifically that part of the phone
perhaps yeah perhaps perhaps perhaps
ma'am mayhaps the thing is how do you
train what's the haps how do you train
the dog to do that without accidentally
calling 911 a whole bunch of times
anyway no no murders there just train my
dog to call 911 can you actually the
operator that has to be on the other
line of that level is your emergency oh
I'm sorry I'm just I'm just rating my
dog to call 911 in case a real emergency
well that's that's got to be a really
hard training thing to do too because
like not only do you have to train the
dog to call or at least to hit the right
speed dial button but you also have to
like simulate a scenario in which that's
the appropriate thing to do yeah and
then or just lavadora they like the DIA
cuz house dog gonna know like yeah can't
cuz like if you feel to that call at 911
call center like what would you do yeah
although hey maybe you know I mean maybe
you think i read maybe the dog will be
on speakerphone with the 911 operator
and I mean that one operator will have
to do the what is it boy to the dog yeah
like a lassie cartoon what is the dog
woof woof fire or less you you know I
read it cuz i read a story just the
other day about a guy who was being a
dumbass with 911 oh god and they found
him yeah and that's illegal yeah and so
like and he didn't like the operator
they talked to Italy yeah people do this
all the time they always prank of it but
this guy didn't bother to like use a
payphone or or block the number
he was called and so why not like a
teenager was nature's yeah he hauled up
and asked where to hose that hahahaha
that's so dumb and and yeah and like it
kept going to cuz she like originally is
like she gave him a response and it
could have ended there but right again
and then he was like so you don't know
where to hose it yeah and so they like
sent people to his place and to school
and they interviewed him afterwards he's
like you know I asked for the hose rad
and they brought me here so I guess all
the hoes are in jail like it not waive
it up I guess I'm the home yeah yeah
it's like not given up on this joke and
like on the one hand you lose you're
wasting time and resources and on the
other hand you're like this kid must it
must have been this kid must have had
the easiest [ __ ] life that's like the
most benign [ __ ] this kid must like
have that this kid must have affluenza
words like he has been so suburban Lee
sheltered he doesn't understand
consequences yeah it's like so great
he's gonna find out where the hoes is it
yeah jail yeah hey he'll be like in a
cell next to a dude that like it has
actually tricked Dean's just like oh oh
so you are one of the hosts twist ending
I was not expecting this twist ending he
finds the hose in jail cuz he's just
arbitrarily in a in a cell with a bunch
of people who were sex workers hey man
if you know where the hoes are at right
into a dank ass studios at p.o box DNK a
Pueblo Colorado we are not based in
Pueblo Colorado no but I was talking
with a co-worker mine and apparently
they would run these old commercials I
can't recount the story properly but
they would run these like clip it's on
TV of like a dude making a sandwich or
whatever and then to be they'd be like
to find out more you know send such and
such to p.o box this you know pueblo
colorado and there are all these
commercials were the mailing address for
whatever thing would be in Pueblo
Colorado I guess there's just easy and
web Oh Colorado's up that kind of
business yeah like apparently la is home
to all of the car designing interesting
like automotive design is censored in LA
okay all right which is
saying of all the of all the things to
be centered net in LA automotive design
not the building just like drawing what
the car would look like so it's pretty I
guess it's because we have all those
design schools I think that's why but
it's also I mean New York has art
schools but but people in New York
design buildings because like people in
New York like less people own cars and
New York wears like la is a very spread
out everybody I know who's ever come to
visit la they always say like yeah la is
a city and its tall but it's also much
more spread out than any other city it's
like Elias like trying to think how to
put it it's like a city but if you set
your TV wrong to like the wrong stretch
mode everything's kind of stretched out
yeah it's a seat it's a city where
somebody [ __ ] up the aspect ratio yeah
it's like it still occupies the same
amount of screen on the y-axis but it's
much more spread out on the opposite
that's why I think like me putting on my
[ __ ] dork ass hat for a second years
that's my feel like la will be a great
setting for another Bethesda fallout
game dude to walk around this like to
walk around like the ruins of a retro
future la you have on fallout new
Sherman oh yeah but now just because I
think that would really work because I
mean I think they've done the California
before in in the follow through that's
been like Bakersfield or small out
Monterey yeah whereas in them like la
you have so much land to work with you
have so many and you have like classic
Hollywood to draw a whole bunch of stuff
from cuz like classic Hollywood you also
have just like a schizophrenic design
yeah because so like even just using
Hollywood or downtown as a microcosm
it's like I've always described it's
like somebody loaded a bunch of ideas
into a cannon it just sort of
haphazardly fired it at the earth it's
like you'll go from like one beautiful
like old historic looking building to
like a shitty Shack to like a really
nice sort of gaudy you know uh you know
person style club or something like that
it's just like there is no rhyme or
reason to the architecture so kind of
there yeah la is la is kind of a
frankenstein city yeah and you can go
from what's really nice to like really
shitty what's also crazy just like the
fact that so many things in LA are built
on other thing
that just you don't know where they are
anymore yeah like Dodger like dodger
stadium was built over uh chavez ravine
which was like this giant Mexican
neighborhood that was this big thriving
community that basically threw a bunch
of really shy story civic landing moves
no God pate like God totally paved over
and destroyed and turned into Dodger
Stadium there's an Eddie Izzard bit
where he's talking about his he's
talking about like how and uh he's
talking about how like in places like
America and you know populated cities in
America people like are shocked if
something's like 50 years old yeah we're
than in this like River School just
building to how it looked over 50 is a
good no one was alive than it's like you
know as in Europe there's a castle
everywhere yeah and so it really does
seem to be like once something gets to a
certain ages like yeah let's just tear
it down and build a parking garage just
as easily its kind of it struck me as
being kind of what's crazy is like you
know what's crazy to find out about la
is you know there's the whole thing
about in The Who Framed Roger Rabbit
where judge doom wants to buy the
streetcar dismantle at pave over
toontown and build a freeway in real
life that's what happened except there
was no toontown to see ya the tire and
automotive companies collectively bought
out all the public transit in la tour up
tracks for streetcars out of the ground
and built in like had freeways built and
then everyone la had to buy a car no
that's that's why that's why driving in
LA is horrible because it was never
built from the ground up for all this
[ __ ] automotive traffic and that's why
you don't see any tunes around cuz
people are so racist against tunes they
do if they drove them out on ya welcome
to Degas I'll just Degas tubs I was [ __ ]
what is this uh this is a hookah that's
not oh [ __ ] don't die it's never
happened before I've never tried to talk
with that much hookah in my pipes
I was going to make a joke about
prostitution but the time seems as
though it is past yeah and we already
got all those jokes out with the where's
the hose at 91 where the hoes i was
listening to a Jim Jefferies bit this
morning were you now yes listen Jim
Jefferies comedy uh yeah you're gonna
ask you know don't tell me i know i mean
i thought you agree go tell temperature
tell me about it I know yeah i was
listening to some jim jefferies a comedy
it started because somebody reposted
that video of the one bit he does about
guns and i was like oh this seems like
this bit trails off and I'd like to hear
the whole thing so I looked up that bit
and then I sort of started just linked
associating over to different bits and I
learned that apparently in Australia
prostitution is legal but only in yeah
like they have legal prostitution but
only in their laws like you cannot take
prostitutes to hotel rooms you can't
pick them up off the street you can only
go to places that are like safe and
regulated Oh interesting and because he
was I guess taking his brother or dear
friend or somebody who had ms to have a
prostitute multiple sclerosis yes
interest mr. he wanted to have that
experience before you know before things
got before things got yeah dad too rough
you know but yeah I guess they have
legal prostitution interesting in a safe
and regulated way I mean listen if
you're and no guns no interesting well I
mean oh yeah that's really I feel like
if you're gonna have prostitution one
safe and regulated to probably don't
have him in the same time those guns
well I mean Australia they outlawed guns
completely and it's I mean it's funny to
hear him describe it cuz there was
basically like the biggest they had this
massacre that I don't know if it's still
the biggest but at the time according to
him it's one of the biggest like gun
massacres that's ever occurred and the
government went yeah maybe no guns and
the people were like yeah and they were
just okay with that yeah and they're
like yeah it's just this is probably a
good idea which is so crazy because just
like I mean how how in the hell have we
had X
burra Madison maybe that's just what we
need maybe we need one big one instead
of all these little not so big oh I hope
not I mean I fear I said maybe but I
hope not cuz that's I mean that's he
this was around the time to Sandy Hook
cuz he's talking he talks about sandy
hook in the bit and he basically says
like so you guys recently had you know a
shooting at an Australian yes oh you
guys recently had a shooting in a school
and it was you know lots of children
around and your government went hey
maybe we should outlawed the big guns
the and fifty percent of you guys went
[ __ ] no like and it was just an
interesting sort of cultural like I feel
like we need to really get rid of the
whole the only thing that stops a bad
guy with a gun is a good guy with a gun
because no well he went on to rip about
the whole like protection bit and he's
like you know again the bid itself like
it's one of those bits worth like it's
still comedy but he's making good point
yeah and at one point he just brought
that up he's like you know so why are
they called assault rifles like where
are these protection rifles I've heard
so much about like cuz again and to it's
like it was where's the rifle that has
like plus twenty defense rating yeah
exactly and he's like you know what is
so so everyone's like I need a gun in
case someone breaks into my house he's
like you know somebody's breaking in
your house chances are they want to
steal your TV or something like that
like you know how like how do you get so
many people who think that they are
important enough or have enough enemies
that people just want to break into
their houses and kill them I don't know
if you like to do this super super super
into buying guns because he thinks he
has a lot of enemies he probably has
made a lot of enemy air probably
possibly buddies like walking around
thinking that all problems can be solved
by him buying a [ __ ] ton of guns I I
decide whether that argument weirds me
cuz I'm like people are panicky though
like yeah like I get it but at the same
time so much could go wrong like like
the ideal version of that scenario like
well if more people had guns X wouldn't
have happened well it's like you gotta
make sure that all those people who are
packing like are calm in a [ __ ] storm
have really good aim that there's not
people in the Ford where like in India
between like that they're able to handle
like panic surrounding them yeah it's
like like situations don't have the vast
amount of control that you know like a
movie scenario would like you imagine
your heads like you know it's not like
one guy's gonna stand up and take the
shot and everything's gonna be great
like there's gonna be utter chaos I just
maybe that's the problem American the
the gun laws is that as a culture we're
all too kind of confident yeah well
that's like we have all they are yeah we
have guys like hunt deer that are just
posting photos of themselves with their
guns cut their gun collections being
like come at me Isis I'm just like you
don't live in a town that has any
symbolic or strategic importance Isis is
not gonna come to your town and if they
come to your town like I'm sorry des
moines ready yeah but if they come to
your town your your your rifle is not
going to outdo a bomb yeah yeah that's
that's the case oh man the world can
that's world [ __ ] chaos man that's
but it was always chaos yeah I know the
world I don't just we don't know if
we're ever gonna get better as a people
hey I gotta I gotta my source of faith
is is trying to look at things hey
Gillian Lee hey Gail ooh vocab me I feel
like we should have like a drop down I
feel like there should be segments and
one of them should involve vocabulary I
was like like the dialectic you know the
idea that basically okay progress is
slow and it's just a matter of you know
we will make one move forward along one
theme but then we realize that that's
too much and then we overcorrect within
a counter-movement and just you know
like like I made a vine recently where
the core fidelity dialectics is these
terms that would be impossible for Mike
Tyson to say because there's so many S's
in th noises it's like so it's like you
know we had start with the thesis like
you know everyone should bethey feel a
fee fifth so we have the thesis and then
we have the antithesis and those two
ideas figure each at like go
head-to-head with each other and
eventually with former synthesis we have
now feces
forming us in thesis yeah so that's so
hopefully that will get us into a nice
synthesis rather than a [ __ ] as
[ __ ] synthesis but i don't know like
i was listening to you were not so smart
and there's this whole episode that came
out not is this a podcast it's a podcast
you are not so smart in math i mention
is on the show before at some point they
did an episode about naive realism we're
basically you know it's like we're all
really bad at thinking that our views
when it comes to politics are along the
spectrum rather than something we
arrived at concretely through objective
facts words like you know there are no
objective political facts in that way
it's just a matter of you know spectrums
of opinions and value systems that are
personal and arrived at through you know
experience and not every experience is
gonna be like enlightening for you but
blinding for someone else oh so it's
like you know we think well it's just a
matter of us of humankind getting better
or it's like no we just kind of go
through these phases of you know one
idea props up a counter idea props up to
combat it and then those two Duke it out
and we kind of form some kind of balance
but the thing is everyone thinks the
balance the moderate is their stance
yeah everyone thinks the people who are
more liberal than me are not are too
idealistic and don't know reality and
the people who are more conservative
than me or callous and wrong and greedy
and greedy or whatever but yeah so um
maybe the world will end maybe it won't
maybe there will be some giant
apocalypse that hits the reset button
maybe there won't I'm [ __ ] out I
don't to I don't to we're not here about
that no I mean this is a free-flowing
park I feel like we could use some
segments I feel like we can use a
skeletal structure for this we're still
figuring yeah I figure like we can use
some segments that recur you know so far
we be getting feedback of why is this
here on the channel because
you know cuz we cuz we can because we
want to put it on the channel you know
variety is a getting different media and
then there's you know I like this this
is cool and then there's premium Dom
saying who actually interacts with our
our topics are comments hey man is dope
pd yeah shoutouts to the pd so it's the
the premiums you are our fan club in our
street team yes one person standing for
us yeah man we appreciate that we
appreciate your time and effort
listening to our bullshitter II yeah
listening to us black dude Emmett Emmett
bro Emmett Emmett is our guard dog
Emmett is our guard dog and he needs a
scratch and a half I don't know i mean
yeah i thought we could introduce a
segment oh yeah yeah but i'm right i
want to tell you about it when we're not
recording so they could ever pops up
then people be like weird this come from
okay you know nothing everybody speaks
in that vocal register I think they all
speak that way that's the voice of the
Internet that's the hmm thank you plug
it here in a joke plane the internet is
Hank hell when you come when you really
think about it read between the lines
people his hand shake it slip oh man
alright well Donald Trump um yeah uh
whatwhat's what should we get into its
let's load up a packet it's novembre
it's no vomits the month of mustaches
and and you know food and questionable
holiday I just love when I saw something
insane on on Twitter it was like these
really you know something comes saw
something insane at the mental hospital
it is um I saw something in saying on
Twitter words that you always know like
a mean has come from an interesting part
of the internet when it's like really
really really compressed and there's a
lot of JPEG artifacts on it and the
image quality is kind of loads like this
was made by somebody who's got a very
old computer and that's always
interesting but it was like a fuzzy
image of like pj from from goof troop /
a goofy movie yeah dude hold on I gotta
continue but I gotta find
tumble and he had his I don't know if I
never watched goof troop and I only saw
the first goofy movie so I know PJ ever
got like like a cute vaguely French
looking girlfriend but it was it looked
like official art this didn't look like
fan art so maybe this is just like from
something that I didn't remember of not
being goof troop viewer thank you moving
about that food about me euro um so DJ
had was like walking and a smile it and
he had like his RT looking girlfriend
like draped over his arm and just like
looking so happy to be with him at PJ is
it you know is it a portly chap and his
his girlfriend was like this like smelt
like dressed totally in like black capri
sweats and like a black sweater I think
turtleneck and a black beret and that's
made in cartoon language that means
party in French okay um and she was like
huddling up next to him and the text set
getting cold out its big boys season get
you one as like somebody there's a very
interesting side of the internet that
just like I hate cold weathers here time
to date a big boy so we can hibernate
together day long he can let me in his
blubber role Oh ladies let me wrap you
in my Bible rule boys be high speed why
is the guy who made this mean like some
weird Cajun I don't know it's as I just
I just imagine you know a jolly a jolly
Cajun man a big aspherical cages yeah
you know you weren't in a fish market
notice how to keep warm this man has to
have a tiny bowler hat that's like
cocked on his head so he's Pete he's a I
guess he's just peed at me then yeah I
had a different dog creature now I do I
saw this isn't what i was thinking of
but I saw like a tweeter or something
where somebody said that the goofy movie
and fury road are both about both of my
character's name max were going a road
trip they don't want to be a hunt yeah I
saw that and I also saw um there was a
tumble I found or
maybe you fed no background yeah i smear
your that shots from shots from fury
road Mack like mapped out with shots
from chicken run and they're really
similar movie the Mad Max the really
similar movies to fury road yeah hey
double feature chicken run and Mad Max
fury road I do love and a goofy movie
and a good triple feature yeah perfect
let's put that on that's if we have our
host an event if dank ass dubs ever gets
on like enough of a consistent track and
we host an event someday or maybe
there's a there's reject con a reject
Kanye waves a dank ass stubs booth or a
just like there'll be team there will be
the day gasps Stubbs table which will
just be a card table with some like a
cardboard sign on it somewhere in the
exhibition hall yeah we'll just you know
what we'll have like one of the little
conference rooms and we'll do a live
episode or something like that but then
after hours we will do a triple feature
screening in no particular order of Mad
Max chicken run in the goofy movie it's
always weird to me how a comic-con de
woods just do movie screenings yeah in
the first year I went I almost attended
to and didn't make it in time for either
I saw I think I first saw hard candy at
a at a comic con screen cuz i really
want to see hard candy I was like well
while I'm here and there's nothing else
on the on the docket that I'm really
interested in let me check it out
nothing like watching Patrick Wilson
being mutilated but it was weird because
it was a double feature with Juno where
I get it Ellie age being to connecting
with you but it's like um what that's a
that's a spicy meatball I'm following
this cool speaking of spicy meatballs
are following this awesome Twitter
account called NYC Guido voice slowed we
talked about this on the last dang casa
yeah we did and there is a there is a
tweet about spicy meatballs that's a
spicy meatball re-sampling them at Whole
Foods you'd go back to the last zdenka
sewed and listen up that [ __ ] cuz cuz
you read that out loud
oh alright so one thing we did promise
to do one thing we did promise on this
episode of day you're holding on you're
like Jared Jared when you're gonna get
up while you promise yeah so we uh Jerry
went through absorption I will last
alone haunt the alone experience index
of absorption part 4 of 4 and and you
know the big the big shoe the really big
shoe you know the the few weeks in
october ax and yeah I went I went
through it to ya know what you think I
mean like okay so cuz you know it's been
a minute for me cuz I saw like I want to
say maybe a week before you did yeah
yeah yeah you you got to check I didn't
know if I was gonna be able to go yeah
it was just kids met they were there you
were yeah you know it's like I it's like
I try to keep abreast of what they're
doing and and and all that and sort of i
kept an eye on the tickets and it was
the sort of thing where it's like enough
time had passed by like the final
weekend of october that i was clear to
start physical therapy so I figured you
know like okay I'll oh yeah I can't not
do it like you know it's my it's like
one of my favorite things about this you
know month and I really loved the last
one so you know I gotta go and I'm and
I'm you know capable enough so I sort of
you know hoping in good faith that they
would be gentle with me at least a
little bit you know I snatched up a
ticket because it was like Wednesday and
they were like we've only got tickets
for Friday and you know they're only a
couple slots so which ended up being
perfect because I wasn't able to work
you know at the haunt that weekend um so
I was gonna be on my own uh for you know
hola on my own or with my folks so I was
like yeah you know um I'm gonna go you
know I grabbed a ticket and so that was
nice evening actually because I end up
doing the pumpkin patch thing with my
folks and then I went to boney Island
which is fantastic or know if you've
have you been to pony no but you told me
about it boney Island is so much it's
like the fun side of you know the
halloween haunt thing it's not like a
haunt haunt but it's you know it's a
it's an
interactive display and it's very fun
and stuff like that so I did that
earlier in the evening and then I went
out to a loan and I I had to bump my
slot to a midnight yeah just do to you
know circumstances and always flaking on
the folks uh so i switched to a midnight
slot and i went in and you know i went
to the building you know sat down i
waited you know is cool vibe is a very
different space i guess there's like an
old film plant or something like that it
shows that they did use that vibe and
the fact that there are like screening
rooms for dailies in the in the building
oh yeah and I mean this was the most
fully realized uh you know is the most
fully realized portion of the of this
you know unweave the rainbow surgery
series yeah um cuz you know i mean the
scare light one like it's in a
conference room so it's like you know I
felt like they did they did their thing
with what they were given their um I
feel like I didn't get to see the one
last year but I feel like the basement
of that other building in LA may have
given just lend it a little more like
creepy vibe yes in the same way like
that if we marry is automatically creepy
because they go to some basement these
spaces in that building they were
crawled under that building yeah I got
pretty big i created with what parts of
the building they use oh yeah so so this
was like a full-on like in a building
you know and you really get the sense
that you were going all over the [ __ ]
place um and this was cool because it
was also like you know it's been a weird
year and it's been a weird October it's
been weird couple months it's been weird
times and so like to kind of ring in
Halloween you know like right at
midnight sitting there waiting to go
into this thing and actually ran into
somebody I sort of know through them and
we went in in tandem so so she went in
just before me which was just a neat
little thing and and yeah like I I
really enjoyed it it is different in
ways from last year but um they got
creative with a lot of things yeah um
that chairman oh yeah the whole chair
thing
and there's um I mean let's go through
what we do remember because the font is
over it's not like we're gonna spoil
anything yeah yeah this is a you know
it's the debrief yeah now that there is
nothing to hide yeah so what's good out
for me first I know there were bits
where they put you in some big screening
rooms where there were mannequin torsos
and heads sitting in some of the the
theater chairs and you had to watch
these really well done little videos I
felt like Tonya ladies kind of new agey
but vaguely like the kind of old 80s and
night like science videos you would
watch in class back in the day yeah
because there are a lot of a lot of give
really grainy film images of just
settings in places then sometimes just
like really up close colors and there's
like a very soothing narration the way
they would have been in like you know
the late 70s of the early 80s just
explaining things to you about light and
color yeah you know with that sort of
analog synth music underneath it like it
was very much like sitting in on an odd
seminar you know yeah and I thought I
was a really cool cuz you know like from
the opposite side you try to think about
it when you're in there but from the
opposite side like this experience is
like a kind of a Rube Goldberg machine
or it's like a machine that's always
running with multiple people in it so I
thought like as a buffer that was really
cool cuz you've got selectively and at
specific intervals people were taken out
of the room press down the hall by you
know and attended with an earpiece so
you always kind of there was a very
specific plan as to when you moved on
and what you didn't yeah and so
sometimes you were alone in that theater
and sometimes you know somebody would
you would be the one shuffling in or
somebody else would shuffle in on you
and they were like you know man like you
said mannequins and the seats and stuff
and it's it's just strange enough cuz
there's nobody else really except the
one attendant and then you're fed
through a hole in the law yeah you know
and forced to come out in in some place
different um ya know so I remember you
know you I went in I was told to choose
one of two doors yeah there were three
doors in that room which was interesting
one was locked so I went through the
door that was not open there was one
that was ajar and I'm curious as to what
was in there yeah
then one of the first things it does is
like send you through one or two doors
but I feel like both those doors
actually let into the same room
interesting which store did you choose
the left or the right can't remember but
I feel like was one of them a jar or no
yeah cuz one looked like there was like
a bathroom or something in her or a
different room yeah it was dark inside
yeah and then I remember that first room
that somebody pulls you into that first
into that room and you're placed and
they shot they selectively click flash
light on and off and yes here are
different sections of the room and they
move you around this rolling chair yeah
and and then they you know they start
giving you this strange monologue and
they they they wrote on my arm I am a
triangle I didn't I I they drew she drew
a triangle on my hand but she wrote I am
NOT a circle all down my forearm yeah um
again I am am at a drawn triangle see
everybody got something a little bit
different ya seen somebody got some
folks got both arms some folks got no
different combinations of drawing versus
letters and stuff um and then you know
next year you are fed up the stairs into
the theater I remember being very
nervous because I caught my shoelace Oh
on the chair and nothing happened like
it didn't [ __ ] anything up but I was
like I wonder if is gonna be weird if I
tie my shoe before dawn the stairs oh
cuz i just did want to trip or anything
um but yeah and then you were taking
like there was I remember you got wet
when you fed through the wall I think
this is the order like the next room was
almost like an examination thing in late
Diana hazmat suit making you yeah in
like a dark room yeah and who would like
examine your hands or something like
that yeah and then you were fed through
another sort of like hole-in-the-wall
ania to crawl through this like tent
area I feel like before you got sent
into the examination room there was a
what something where a guy was like
rustling with a bunch of papers they
looked really stressed just right there
yaz is he he sits you down again and
like moves you as if you're in the way
as he's like rifling through his giving
you files to hold on to a lot of files
were just torn up yeah a lot of I was
just torn up and and and sort of
unintelligible and I'm looking at them
cuz I'm like a should I be taking note
of this earlier
anything written on here I tried to read
warning I tried to actually take one and
feel like maybe I can read this later
because they all look like they have
weird stuff like scrawled on them I
tried to take one but he caught me and
stolen stolen back I'm going to be
honest with you I do have a little piece
of the experience of me oh yeah yeah it
was in the record room the record room
other episode n at such I'm very much a
priest after the examination you go into
and this is the part where it's clear
that they they made good use of the of
the the fact that this is like a former
film lab there was this this hallway
this corridor with a bunch of doors and
they were labeled rooms like like this
was a film studio there was the record
room um there was the claymation room
there was a room that said Enola like
the old Enola foundation play and it had
a powered keypad lock on it and I
couldn't figure out the combination to
open the door all you got to do that or
no I got to at least interact with it
yeah I saw but I didn't get to touch it
and there were people there were guys
dressed in like corporate attire walking
backwards through the room through the
corridor as you're in that corridor damn
i wish i could cuz and it was on the
business cards oh i never got the
business card they handsome in the lobby
I i didn't i didn't foolios there they
weren't they didn't make a deal out of
it but they did have a little tray of
business cards and I I thought to grab
one cuz I was like oh maybe like you
know and and I didn't ever get I don't
think I've really had a chance to
interact with that door although one of
their guys did open a padlock door for
me or like a keycode door for me I just
don't know if it was the same one yeah
but in that corner the record room I had
a but it was full absolutely full of
smash records and Nash records and torn
up horribly leaves and stuff like that
invited to I wasn't I didn't spend much
time in that room but you were invited
to smash some of those records I spent
some time in there yeah yeah smash some
of the records I mean one of the guys
started throwing pieces of the of the
torn up sleeves at me so we're just kind
of all like Nina wandering around
this is part of the cool thing is it's
sort of what you put into it what you
decide to do with this odd you know
prompt so you know we're picking stuff
up and sort of throwing things around
and walking and and you know breaking
things and I I started they had a record
player on the one side of the room and I
started like just putting little pieces
on it to try and make like a spinny
triangle on it um so yeah it's just like
you kind of do whatever in that room and
so we started like throwing bits of
things up in the air and at each other
on but i found a torn-up piece of a
record sleep that had a triangle drawn
on it huh-uh so II I have just a torn-up
record sleeve peace with the walls red
trying on then there was the claymation
I do I really like the clay major
Plantation was awesome there was a clay
man it was a claim a yeah just like this
got this actor whose face wasn't
completely encased in like model magic
brown clay well that was what he was
made out of yeah that was it was all
over his hand so it just looked like his
hands in his head were just sort of like
he was transitioning from clay and to
you know yeah clay to skin to clay and
rule in the walls end up and the floor
was covered in clay smears and they he
gave you a bit of clay and invited you
to use it to write on the walls yeah huh
yeah he took my hand and sort of you
know rubbed it in it and then yeah you
know it just started writing things on
the wall you know and that was which was
awesome like I was so that was the part
works like this is low five but this is
really cool this is the part where you
actually feel that was a part were dealt
like they put some effects into this
where there's there is something that is
not human right there yeah exactly you
know affected in a very kind of like
budget loaf I way yeah what and I and I
appreciate the way they do that too
because the enola the enola show last
year they didn't do the same thing but
there were occasional rooms where they
have more it seemed like more acrobatic
performers in these I don't know how you
would describe them because the light
was low and be because they looked
unnatural but you would have these weird
unnatural sort of creature II moments
and I thought that was a really cool one
and it's also like you know you you you
you're really willing to go for it and
put your hands in the clay and start
drawing on things it's like you are
leaving a piece yeah in the piece I'm
really bummed rinse your hands off
afterwards yeah thankfully Amanda growls
lots of paper towels what you were just
supposed to throw on the ground I didn't
I didn't get paper towels I was given a
bag at some point and me being practical
I was just like I'm gonna put my hand in
the bag because i still had clay on my
hand uh so and then it eventually dried
but I think um you know um was there
another room in that whole section there
was records there was claymation there
was the enola room whatever was behind
you go through the holiday inn venue
okay so there's the the desk where the
dudes handing things then you go into
the first examination room then you
crawl into the second there's another
examination room with a guy with the
water you yeah something was water
Angeles is your hands off yeah and then
then you get sent through another thing
I'm getting a little blurry the next
before the records room I know I was
pulled into a bathroom and like I took
the lights off and it was another thing
like with the flashlight where where he
was examining you except he would click
that light off and then clicking on
again and he was all of a sudden over
here and then he was down here and then
you know it was like a you know a really
clever low fine he was really good at
moving quietly so each time he'd pop up
it was disconcerting was like oh like
you know you're now you're on my left
now you're over here you know now you're
checking my face out you know and then
after records was for me anyway after
records and after clay it was the like
the the guy running the tab running the
numbers there was a guy to desk yeah
running numbers and who was like talking
to you about you know they threw up a
quote from that from that scene um
basically about [ __ ] I'm looked as if
did you talk to that guy that like there
wasn't i can't remember you were pulled
into her a big room with like a desk and
there's a guy sitting at the desk and
he's you know it's it's sort of like a
corporate office almost and they're like
you know we've been waiting for you like
you and you're late you know oh that's
right come on I he leads you into a
stairwell yeah and
almost like a job interview it is it's
before that was before that it's you sit
down across from this guy okay and he's
talking to you you're the only person
it's a pretty big room to and you're
like the only person I think there was
like a pile of something behind me a
sort of a disconcerting pile and then
your your let out of that room
eventually and I remember it being
strange because like at first it's just
like being pulled into a scene of a
terry gilliam movie where it's just like
it's loud and this guy is like clearly
moving at a pace like you know is he's
doing desk work and crunching numbers
and talking to you very like crazy
disconcerting bureaucracy yeah and it's
like this disconcerting thing that's
behaving as though you're a part of it
and it's not really acknowledging that
you might not be yeah so like you're
automatically pulled into this odd
situation where they're like yes you
know and there was something about you
know there was something about you know
having to go out of their way to do all
this work based around you and hire
actors to fill your life and you know
sort of to you know study up on you and
to be around to pose as friends and
things it was WOW very it was a very
strategy bat talk that sounds [ __ ]
crazy yeah um I think they there was a
there was a moment he he had there where
he said something that we are not about
profit margins but I'm much more
fiscally concerned with human my
remember that okay yeah member somebody
told me that yeah and just a little yeah
yeah um and now they have a new logo
which is wicked yeah um but yeah it was
so that was like a really sort of
strange and disconcerting but very cool
you know dialogue piece I was I was a
little unsure of what to say cuz he was
he's Yvonne a groove and he was moving
at such a pace yeah I think that's kind
of part of the point I had a similar
either similar guy talking a similar way
but he led me away and like told me to
go down stairway and say something that
was the next part from me was I was I
was pulled out of that room and actually
just before the music changed because
like the music I came in on was
something like disconcertingly pleasant
it was like a pleasant music and then
three quarters of the way through that
scene the music shifted to like a weird
electronic droning noise I think I feel
like I remember the music shift which
yeah was just like who like
disconcerting and then I was let out of
that room eventually and at the top of
the stairs this guy greeted me who is
like fast-talking he's like you're gonna
do great we believe in you you're a
perfect addition to this organization
you know now I just need you to do one
thing and one thing only and I know
you're gonna nail it is like being
really really motivational and really
lots energy yeah I was told to go down
the stairs and scream at the top of my
lungs I think it was something like
envelop me in darkness or so yeah I'd
like embrace me with dark ever hug me
with darkness something like that yeah
the thing is that room that bonnet era
were supposed to yell that is behind a
curtain John Curtin which blocks you
from the check-in area so when you first
check in your first agree more you hear
people behind that curtain screaming bad
things like that totally apropos nothing
yeah and it's and and so I was sitting
there were for the experience being like
what is this an actor like is this
something is this part of the thing or
or or are they you know what is this
gonna be um and then the next room I
think was the was one of the pitch black
ones right yeah I got pulled into a
pillar a pitch black room and I think
that the actor there spun me yeah you
were spun around the room in the dark
like up against the wall and stuff like
that which was you know strange and
disconcerting and kind of scared it's
like kind of physically scary because
you're trying not to trip on anything
there at least with me they're very good
at at sort of controlling chaos you know
I was never I never felt like I was
always kind of liked her but never like
oh they're gonna drop me you know um see
I was spun around and then oh yeah and
then um [ __ ] what happened after that
there was something there were certain
rooms was where did the pillow fight
room followed all this was it earlier oh
maybe because there's no there's a lot
crawling underneath like a bunch of
drape blankets at some point you crawl
in
do this kind of like bigger draped
blanket chamber where there's kind of a
guy dressed in like a big long shabby
coat who has like a pillow fight with
you yeah yeah they're very happy it was
very happy very happy very childlike
yeah just in a mound of pillows and
stuffed animals and he hands you one and
then he starts hitting you with his yeah
he has you hit him back and we had a
pillow fight yeah and then we hugged
yeah they're like and then there was
some weird like hand clapping pattycake
yeah I play a honey cake yeah and then
it's like when I had to go on my way he
was like slapping me on the ass with his
pillow to get me to mush yeah I think it
was the first time I spoke to him I was
like I think it was the first time I
spoke to anybody outside of like when I
was prompted I was just like I'm going
I'm going hey uh where did that cuz that
you what did you do you crawled crawled
out you crawled out oh man see ya it's
all out of order in my head I'm a link
that goes I feel like that eventually
leads into the second screening room
that's right there is another screening
room man where you come in the other
side yeah so it's yeah you come in a
different side but they're similar
mannequins spaced out and a similar
movie playing but you can tell it's
different yeah is a is a different one
um god there's like I'm to grunt one
room with a girl before the second
screening room works like there was some
kind of talk or some kind of interaction
and there I remember that led to the job
interview we type stuff about being late
oh that's right the girl leading into
that second screen room I feel like she
gave me the late talk and then the job
interview fast-talking guy that let me
down the stairwells like kind of gave me
the second half of that oh I feel like
they may have done a little bit of
restructuring as poss as the show's gone
on um that seems to be the way I mean
then eventually you you end up in the
more bally sections of the room yeah I
mean you you eventually come upon the
unicorn yeah but before that you go into
a pitch dark room where there's a CCTV
camera talking to you and someone
talking to you over the PA yes to me was
asking things like how often do you
your mustache huh oh man I'd like you I
should have interacted with that more I
couldn't tell if it was real and the guy
was asking i find you utterly
fascinating damn yeah so it's like i was
able to have a back-and-forth with
whoever was on the other line of that
but when I I put my hands on the table
where this camera was set up and
everything it said don't don't touch me
oh I was like who saw as if as if the
camera was him that's awesome and I know
there are several rooms with their just
TVs in there that would just playing
static and its really creepy yeah to
walk into just a blank room with the
team a bunch of TV's on the floor like
should i investigate this or yeah just
keep moving yeah yeah no that they they
did that there's that one transition
where they put you in that role played a
blindfold you they put a sheet over your
head yeah and then they roll you back on
this chair and tip you through into the
next bit share tips over then it's all
like a track and they they track you
into the next room under some curtains
where where did I get painted I feel
like that right then that's where it
happens this this um this guy no it has
a bunch of talcum powder day sprays on
you that but the paint is in a different
room oh that's right whales paints my
painting my face you feel like you're
getting processed at that point yeah it
was in one of the maybe it's just before
the spinning or maybe was it in one of
the sort of more office e rooms or the
more like chemicals would be here rooms
yeah where somebody I think it was a
woman you know started painting my face
and the layer yeah they the guy
basically covered me in this powder yeah
um and then it was there there was the
big like hanging chair thing yeah there
was like a swinging hammock chair they
like spun you around and and moved you
through then you come to these giant
kind of underground II rooms where it's
just uh this just massive massive pitch
black chamber with just a a weird grated
crawl space underneath that you have to
climb down
crawl into which is mad trippy they had
like a green lathe like that a laser
projected down yeah so at a certain
point you do sort of feel like you're
just crawling up a light spiral into
shadowy oblivion but at the there's a
little girl in a unicorn kigurumi that
leads you down into the first woman
first yeah dances on you she asked me
she had me give her a piggyback ride
yeah what Eric okay what Erika went
through like she she gave Erica a
piggyback ride which was weird because
the the girl was the girl was really
petite I wonder due to longer was very
petite I wonder who that might have been
if it was the twins cuz they're there
are these pair of twins these identical
twins that are that were actors and past
alone things yeah i'm curious now I on
either end of so I was like the giant
this giant room that feels like it
belongs in [ __ ] house of leaves man
all underground through a crawlspace
another giant room and on the other side
the gyro ms another little unicorn girl
yes who leads you into the next area
thing I mean like that is a big that was
a big room with a lot of greats and
things yeah so it's just like it's a
it's a cavernous room bally and
industrial yeah it's just it's it's one
of those like it's just disconcerting to
be there like you you're just sort of
looking all around the room and like you
just get in because they're making you
focus on light and shadows just shadow
becomes its own character almost yeah so
it's like you're very conscious of the
corners of the room and things like that
um and then yeah what was after that was
i'm sure i'm missing certain things yeah
it's been so long since we actually did
it it's like i want i want to go to
another one already that with that level
of production yes cope with that scale I
get the end and I mean I remember I then
the big sort of the last time we were in
was um yep the big with it was like this
big big room with its chain
think on one side had this light and
this fog sort of pouring down yeah you
can't really see things well at all
visibility super low and and had I mean
there was there was this a tall uh I
don't know which which which one to use
there was this tall guy and address yeah
cuz I wish he's a me cuz I know the
actor because the actor had been in past
alone experiences he was in the
scavenger hunts noted in January but
he's like at all kind of athletic build
black guy with a shaved head and he was
in this really elegant dress and I and
he grabs you and he swings you around
and like like does this really gentle
swinging dance with you around the room
and then he leads you out through a
doorway and the next thing you know
you're just in this empty courtyard like
in the back of a building well yeah you
like pressed me up against it yeah and
gave a just enough of a push for the
wall to give and I was out in the
courtyard met by two dudes we like let
dant that hold and like there was a
couple times where we did that where we
would basically clasp hands and in
circles you know yeah you know just
faster and faster almost like you're in
a field of some kind like like you would
see people do disguise yeah dancing in
circles but in the last room like we
like he embraced me at one point like we
embraced each other yeah he was really
he was like really intimate and like
really really putting on the embrace
yeah and then and then you wound up in
the courtyard in there were there were
just two guys kind of stand-in there
yeah just hang it out hanging out and
then you sort of they got a little
closer and I sort of started to walk
like I guess I'm just gonna walk through
yeah and then they like both embraced me
from either side I didn't get that part
oh yeah like a super hug and then I went
into the Delilah lounge which was you
know
brightly colored in musical and had some
interesting little artifacts in there
there was another like additional room
in the lounge that you could go into yes
which was we were pulled into that yeah
that room but yeah it was uh and then I
got like a tackle hug yeah like a tackle
hug at the end there like hugs they do
this this is like to embrace you yeah
this this part was all about hugs yeah
so it wasn't it didn't have the story of
the enola foundation that implicit
narrative in there it didn't have that
this is a thing this is a in the
universe of the event you're going into
a a weird kind of a new AG center that's
gonna process you but it felt like it
was interesting because they felt like
there was the character of an
organization in there that that was
alone inc that wasn't that was corporate
and kind of their motives were kind of
impossible and i feel like this is in
broad strokes what I wanted out of going
to an alone experience the only thing is
like how I wish it was like I wish it
was more were you know what I mean I
wish it was denser there were parts i
felt like they were kind of spaced or
airier empty like you know transitional
spots but it's like I wish there was I
wish it was thicker you know mm-hmm he
was a thicker pudding yeah well I mean
it to I mean I guess we have sort of
different perspectives in a way because
your first experience in mine were
different yeah so it's like you've
gotten acquainted with at least some of
the aesthetics you know in time over the
past you know a few indices and doing
the scavenger and stuff like that yeah
um so it's like it'sit's yet and I mean
this one was i'm trying to think back
because the enola show was really tight
and this was i thought this was really
tight too and i was the most realized
version of all the ones that I
got to experience from this yeah from
this index I feel like the enola one may
have been more but as you put it but but
that could also just be because that was
my first time and it was so you know
everything is so vivid your first time
yeah you know um but yeah I was
definitely this one of all of them was
definitely the most like what I had been
craving yeah it did have that feeling to
it and it's like the the set pieces that
really hit really hit yeah they take the
claymation man or the or the you know
just the the experience of that whole
corridor with all these weird bizarre
rooms works like the thing is what I
wanted the claymation room door was
closed I did not know what to expect and
just said claymation and when I opened
that door I was so shocked yeah I did
not even just smeared with this clay and
looked just scurrying kind of
scatological and reminded me I don't
you've ever seen mulholland drive I have
seen half of mall Andhra which half the
latter half okay because there's
something that happens at the beginning
half that kind of hits that same chord
of you know suddenly something totally
shocking shows up and you don't know
what to what to make of it and it's got
sort of a similar texture yeah so I
don't think anything's ever gonna
compare to walking into that claymation
room is seeing that yeah um and the room
it's like you know the the the unicorn
girls like we're kind of interesting and
kind of interested this the experience
of being about giant vast chamber and
have his little unicorn dance around you
did she did she like wiggle her butt in
front of your crotch yes okay so it
wasn't just me and it wasn't just Erica
but i mean i get i get the sense that
certain things you know certain things
will recur I mean and also you know
depending on who's in there and and I
get the sense that they probably
especially in that role have a relative
amount of freedom but yeah but uh cuz
like there was no there was no
piggybacking with me yeah I maybe they
got the memo that that you're you were a
little bit in for EMA
you're like I let's not break them yes
let's not let's not damage this man and
it just like I feel I don't know the to
me it's like the because of the way
panned out the ending with the dance
just let me into that courtyard and I
actually walked around the alley and you
tried to get my bearings before going
into the lounge so it's like I could
have easily just left and not had that
final little easter egg at the end of
the lounge in that in the room with the
light board yeah yeah so to me it's
almost like I I'm in a way kind of
nervous because it's like I I almost
lost out a little bit of the of the
experience by you know the fact that
that that part was just kind of there
wasn't a specific kind of climax or a
finale mmm i mean the the dancing at the
very end felt like yeah it's a that's
the climax that's the finale but it only
feels that way in retrospect it's like
when I was dancing around it's like I
didn't realize this was the end at the
time hmm and then going on to the quarry
I was like well that felt kind of abrupt
yeah so I think it I think it always
will I don't know I mean it depends on
how it grows and I didn't get to see the
first year or the first year was more a
bit more grounded in a bit more intense
yeah the virtual it was more overtly
scary yeah and this is more Moody yeah
and and even perhaps slightly more so
than enola like this one is more strange
and abstract not that enola wasn't cuz
it very much was yeah but in a different
way and this didn't feel hostile in the
way that a normal haunt is supposed to
feel this felt more kind of alienating
when it wet at its most at its most
hostile it was just alienated hmm yeah
it definitely has a different and I
appreciate that about them is they have
a sort of subtly different vibe each
time and it's sort of a different
permeating tone and mood
because like the enola foundation had
this had this quality that was very much
like on the one hand so soothing
new-agey yeah and on the other but just
beneath it very sinister and very sort
of like cultish yeah like quite trust
him yeah yes you never quite got or you
were never quite comfortable in that um
in again in a good way um but yeah I
mean it is a bit of an abrupt ending but
I feel like it was a very intimate
ending and it's the most striking visual
aside from perhaps the the clay man yeah
cuz you especially when you came in that
room to see her him her in that doorway
with the smoke coming down it was just a
very striking and it was so good what
yeah cuz it was like oh this is an
elegant figure and it's a completely
different vibe in this room it feels
like when you when it first appears it's
it really doesn't until you get close
and you realize what it is it doesn't
feel it doesn't feel man or woman yeah
or or imagining yeah just this
androgynous figure which is great which
is you know so yeah I'm curious to see
what they're gonna do with intimate yeah
what does this I mean that has any
having new details popped up about
intimate I don't believe so or not that
I've seen I mean not that like terms you
know is exactly what they do but that
one does sound intense yeah or at least
it sounds like it would be especially
jarring in a very specific kind of way
cuz it's tailored to you yeah so I'm
very interested to see where they what
they I'm concerned of is cost because
this costs fifty bucks a ticket which
yeah I mean it was that yeah which I
mean I don't know what standard for a
haunt um concerning the first one was
thirty bucks or the first index of the
series was thirty bucks a head uh that
this this show is usually 50 or 60 I
think we paid 50 or 60 last year okay
the october one
just because it's the biggest production
it's the most space it's yeah 45 to an
hour you know instead of 20 to 30 to you
know 45 so yeah yeah I mean that's for
this particular on and for these more
specialized you know like you sign a
waiver and it's you know more exclusive
like those usually cost a bit more yeah
then a regular I think I mean I think
blackout is more and some of the other
ones that are more like plays and things
like that but but yeah that's that's
about the going right I believe they did
they did have a discount running up
front yeah it was like ten or fifteen
dollars off or you can go as I think
there's some way to get tickets to be
part of the like test dress rehearsal
yeah there were preview tickets yeah but
I almost feel like this is something you
kind of want to not do a preview on you
want to go in when they got the rhythm
in the into prov the process down pat
see it's like if I had my druthers I
would love to go like the first or like
the second weekend and then the last
weekend yeah just to see cuz I gotta you
know again these these shows I get the
sense are very much alive and so like to
go towards the big not at the beginning
but towards the beginning and them to go
again towards the end would be a really
cool way just to see what has changed
what has made me been streamlined what
is what I moved around when I walked out
it just like I really did have the
feeling of I wanted I want to do it
again I didn't get to but I had the
feeling of I want to do this exact thing
again and just sore see it twice yeah
which you know I yeah I love when I walk
out of something and feel that way yeah
exactly I mean it definitely has a
tangible effect you know it's it probes
your brain matter a bit more you know
cuz that was my initial thought to was
like [ __ ] I want to do this again but
they're all sold out for the weekend
yeah you know so that was the
conversation I had upon walking it was
just like I gotta do this more than once
next time
do you cuz it you know it always that
might be the next phase is like it
always changes each time and you'll be a
little bit more I imagine aware of your
limbs with each subsequent one um but
yeah I'm curious to see where they go
you know curious to see what they how
this year's uh you know event sort of
shaped things and what they're going to
take from that what they're not going to
take from that because this far it's way
too early this far they haven't let on
to anything about what the next cycle is
gonna look like yeah yeah and and you
know I get the sense that in doing this
in four parts now they've run a course
where the scavenger hunt I think was
sort of designed to close out that story
yeah um and yeah so I know they're doing
the the specialized thing in i believe
it's january says their website but yeah
it's it's much too early to know what
the what the next like show show will be
yeah oh yeah man oh man yeah i'm glad
you guys got to go to that one yeah i'm
glad i got to do it too it's just like
hey I guess I I feel like I want
something more maybe specific out of it
okay yeah I mean this one was a more
vague yeah this felt very vague it was
it just it had moments that were just
really cool and it's like I want I want
to consistent layer of that you know
it's like I kind of want I want
everything to either be the dance party
room at the first one of this year or
the or the or the the the wax really
good homeless guy accurate this year
scavenger hunt section or or the you
know the claymation record room corridor
it's like I kind of want I want
something that's full of those very
specific moments you know that were I
want every room to kind of have that
really striking kind of
key to it yeah which is hard to demand
that to somebody well yeah and it's a
shifting you know entity and I wonder if
maybe the the enola one may have had
more of that specifically yeah um
because they're a lot of striking things
that are remember from that and there
was some very strange girls there's
always strange but um there were a lot
of times when you would be one-on-one
with certain I don't know characters or
people this I don't know there's just
there's you know there's a different a
markedly different aesthetic you know
vibey thing I don't know also what the
means are from show to show yeah you
know cuz i know i don't know they had a
sponsored lounge afterwards yeah and
this one I don't know if they were
sponsored by that but they had died a
bolo sodas there huh in the lounge which
I don't know if they were their drink
sponsors this year maybe yeah it's
entirely possible but I guess we will
see where it goes i mean i'm i'm a i'm
personally a huge fan so i will keep you
know i always keep an eye out for
whatever they're up to likewise so you
know so if you're in the LA area and you
if any of this sounds appealing check
out alone oh yes i mean i don't know if
there's any other haunt quite like it no
i don't i there's creep LA which I want
to check out I wanted to check out creep
too and I would have if I hadn't you
know yeah if it hadn't been questionable
cuz I think they were a bit more
aggressive yeah um yeah there are a lot
of these border lines now like creep I
thought would be interesting because
their whole bent was like you know
humans are the scariest thing of all you
know or that's what you know I read
their sort of about page and they're
like yeah most man is the warmest place
to hide exactly and so they they seemed
like it would be it would be cool to try
them out there's also something um I've
been hearing about lately called I think
it's called fear is what we learned here
I've also heard it referred to as the
dream it's basically it's by invitation
interest um and it's supposed to be they
kind of put you through a dream as it
was described to me like the first part
they like select you like I don't know
what the selection process is but they
select you it's very sort of exclusive
and then you have to go to this some
sort of a location that you're given and
somebody meets you and then they put
like a big heavy jacket on you and
headphones they put you in this bed and
then whisk you away and then whisk you
into this thing you have to sort of go
through and there and they do sort of I
guess a similar thing where they
interview you you know they they ask you
about certain fears you have beforehand
and stuff like that and I guess it's
tailored I like nobody's told any
specific details obviously because
that's you know the nature of a lot of
these sorts of things and the only
reason we're talking details now is
because you know this particular chapter
is over ya know so this is retrospective
and even hearing about it like it's it's
very different from experiencing but
yeah I don't know much about fears what
we learned here but it seems like it's
certainly surreal and scary I feel like
maybe that's something that's gonna be a
really cool new push in in the haunt
seen because like you know alone has
started this whole thing of okay if you
want to scare somebody you don't have to
throw them around it gets super
aggressive you don't have to be verbally
abusive you don't have to just you know
dial up the loud in the shock and
they'll Gore and the whatever in the
aggression what you can do is give
somebody that's not exactly a haunt
that's more surreal or more moody or
more atmospheric in an interesting way
and I feel like now that that idea is
out there whether it's a loan or one of
these other guys that are starting to
starting the crop up someone is going to
do something extremely cool with it I
hope so I now that this idea has been
sort of it's starting to spread like
somebody's going to
put together the one to go to yeah the
definitive big time surreal pseudo haunt
well and and as these get more popular
and it's and as they start to develop
longevity and stuff like that you know
it's like a loan will be moving into its
fourth year next year yeah and you know
you've got more of these popping up the
possibilities might expand nothing you
want like heavy amounts of like backers
but you know like you the means to do
something even bigger will probably you
know present themselves cuz I mean with
a loan they have to do so much with just
whatever the the location gives them you
know and they do a lot with just
blacking things out and specific lights
and just like little decor that they can
find him string together and you know
they do a lot with blankets or pillows
or stuff like that but what I what I
really want is that experience of
walking into a right I want that
experience like I had walking into the
claymation where I have walked into a
room that should not exist yeah i have i
have like walked into something that
would only exist in a movie one and and
the Indianola show had a certain sense
for that because there was a heavy
amount of like there was a uniformity to
a lot of the rooms and a lot of the sort
of dressing in the the unweave the
rainbow stuff and the enola one I mean
there was that sort of new agey
enlightenment thing but there were also
a good amount of just differently themed
rooms like one looked like a diner one
looked like um you know like I like a
pillow fort of some kind there was one
that was um kind of like an empty
warehouse space there was one uh that
was like a weird cult chamber thing I
remember I saw photos of one that was
supposed to be like a weird dinner room
yeah there was a weird dinner room it
was like really well said dressed and
there was like a big you know heavy
table and it looked kind of like a
kitchen yeah and then you know they were
also in between rooms as well but you
the building had a different
architecture but it felt like there was
a variety of like styled rooms that
way and I guess that's I guess that's
what I want out of alone just more that
more that production value yeah yeah I
mean this one was a little more it
didn't dress this space was its own
dressing I guess yeah sort of like they
really ran with the theme of the
building as a whole so there was sort of
a uniformity they're havin to play with
the film lab aspects over here there
yeah so yeah I get wishes and I'm
wondering if maybe you know just going
into the next one if they'll work some
of those things back in or mill you know
you never know if it's gonna abstract
further or come back down to some place
more distinct distinct ER or human I'm
sorry not just ink distinct distinctive
all distinctive distinguishable well
yeah so yeah so that God is the finale
of haunt season what else its finale
upon season all that I mean there are
things that still run i was reading
about heretic house just the other day
that seems like i mean their extreme to
their their extreme in a way that
intrigues me but the eye because like it
is kind of more violent like a blackout
is but in a very with a very different
sort of attitude almost um so those
curious about them I know sinister point
does like a Christmas haunt every year
oh that's you know like Christmas themed
um and some of these places especially I
mean the escape rooms stay open
year-round and there will be you know
some kind of intimate alone experience
in January um but yeah it is the end of
like the market how did aunt season how
did Ryan feel about the gallows haunt he
really enjoyed it I wish me well we I'm
gonna ask him about it cuz I thought we
would have talked about it more I would
have seen a video and maybe I just
missed it cuz so many one up somebody go
up but on yeah but he seemed a really
good time and they use like a whole they
rent it out like it closed down high
school or something for it or some kind
of building that pass flow enough for a
high school and that's you know it's who
I the movie wasn't apparently that great
yeah I haven't seen it yet so I'm
curious because it
I don't know a lot of people who liked
it but I I did hear a number of things
in the softer reviews or even just like
the reviews that bother to cite what did
work a lot of people basically said like
at least on as a technically
constructive found-footage movie it's
actually pretty solid like there it does
manage despite like any other things
that are wrong they said it did manage
to elicit like some genuinely eerie
moments and things like that so unto me
I'm i think i'm just for her so I feel
like just from here on out I'm always
gonna be super skeptical of any of any
um what's the word of any horror movie
that uses the pitch no not uses the
found footage trove but I am skeptical
of those but I'm gonna be skeptical of
any horror movie that has a trailer that
focuses on night vision reaction shots
hey when yeah because at that point
you're not telling me anything about the
movie it's like you're your sake but
it's really scary you do it's like well
at that point it's like well then this
isn't a movie this is a theme park ride
yeah you know it's like if you're
selling me just on the face I will make
then that's not how you sell a movie
that's how you sell a roller coaster oh
yeah I mean I I almost does always
strike me more as as not just going put
it scary though it's almost like it's
going it's scary trust me like huh and
you know it's the trust me that's sort
of like said why you're loosening your
collar you know yeah so it's like little
scary yeah I promise trust me that's
gonna be scared i promise Leah so here
look look these people got scared like
yeah you know I can see yeah that's like
the movie has nothing to nothing to rely
on other than it will make me jump in my
seat won't say I'm sorry yeah a sudden
loud noise in a dark room is gonna make
me jump and I see no matter what oh yeah
it is a move that seems to sort of I
mean I imagine it one time you probably
could have used it effectively because
they did that all the time in like the
things like the 60s and 70s and stuff
where they would have all these trailers
for movies that didn't actually show you
parts of the movie or they would show
you like little
interspersed with like people warning
you not to see it or claiming it's too
scary yeah like that's it that's you
know that's been around for a long time
and the audience of Tingler yeah and the
audience jumping at the screen you know
the reaction shots and the trailers it's
like I think it could have been used
genuinely at one point but now it does
seem sort of like I don't we we're not
sure if any of this footage is gonna
read a scary enough so we're just going
to show you people being scared so that
maybe you'll think you'll be scared yeah
like it just seems like a little more of
a scramble or a or a substitution
meanwhile it's like I saw the trailer
for and I hate them go back to this
movie again I saw the trailer for
goodnight mommy and it was just like
that trailer got me yeah totally and I'm
and I mean that that you know is a
different tone I guess you know because
that movie has a lot of space and
stillness I would imagine yeah like you
got basically hold on surreal things
yeah for longer than like a
found-footage move you would let you hey
guys it's Jerry here we're going to take
a quick break we'll be back with more
dank ass stuff so keep an eye on that
youtube there for part two hope you
enjoyed the first half and we'll see you
soon stay back